[inaudible].
So with that being said about the technological component,
watching cable news shift right now,
there's also an issue that a lot of people are getting their news from this,
from this show shows like this Shapiro wrote in all of these guys that's kind of
worrying to at some level,
right?
And I say that I'm talking about guys that I love,
but like,
just that,
you know,
the fact checking is different here than say it would be on cable news.
Not that cable news has done a great job.
No,
but you're right.
I mean,
we're part,
you know,
we're,
we're always,
uh,
a point on a continuum and we're,
we're in the middle of a cycle where the media are being reinvented completely.
And you're right.
I mean,
the problem with individual operators,
solo guys on Youtube is they have so much less to lose than a television network
does.
That the incentives to get the facts right or be responsible of course,
much lower.
Um,
the problem is,
as you well know better than anybody,
is that the media has so discredited themselves that it's like,
it's so obviously propaganda.
But did you ever think it could be that bad?
No,
I never did.
Every day I look at a story from CNN or political and forget buzzfeed and all
those other like forget the really bad ones vox.
And it's like everything you guys are doing,
every headline and the way every Republican has a picture that they look awful
in the picture.
Democrats look great and like every little thing,
it's like they're just
smashing us with it.
They just turn it up to 11 and I've,
I mean,
I grew up in a media family and when my dad was anchor here in la of ABC,
and so I,
I,
I've always lived in this world and I always thought the media are liberal,
but I was totally wrong about that.
They're not ideologues actually,
their party people.
That's what I totally missed.
They are loyal to the party.
They feel powerless except as part of a group that is the main distinction
between left and right in this country.
And so whatever the Democratic Party's imperatives are,
they will act on them.
If the Democratic Party invaded Canada tomorrow,
they wouldn't see I'm serious.
They'd be like,
you know these Canadians,
they live among us there.
You know what I mean?
They're a fifth column like they would actually do.
It doesn't matter what the product does,
they will defend it.
Once you understand that,
that it all makes sense.
They feel threatened.
That's the truth and you and people like you are the main threat to them.
It's not me actually I'm on a competing medium,
but in the same medium they are.
They know that their power is ebbing and when you feel like you're losing
control,
that's when he tried to assert control.
That's when the most ludicrous propaganda comes when you feel like,
you know,
oh my gosh,
they're not listening to me right after the yell.
The
funny part is I owe and I tweaked this all the time.
It's like if these guys had just been like pretty bad.
Yeah,
I think it would have been tolerable.
People would have because it had been happening for so long.
People kind of wooded and have noticed that maybe they could have got a little
worse than we would have been okay with it.
But it's like they've just completely bottomed and
well,
this is one of the criticisms of Trump that has a lot of truth in it.
When people were like,
well,
he's a destroyer.
He destroys everything he touches,
you know,
probably an overstatement.
But he does,
you know,
you get close,
you sit and stare at Trump all day and you're going to burn out.
You're okay.
You are.
And this,
one of the things I try not to do,
I don't do a show about Trump.
I didn't write a book about Trump.
I'm not against Trump.
I think Trump is useful in a truth teller in some ways,
but,
but the people who obsess about Trump are destroyed.
And that would include his opponents,
maybe especially his opponents.
So what would you do to get some of those people back if they're,
if they're out there now,
the ones that really are overboard on Trump that I haven't,
you know,
I've been able to reach them,
some liberals and good lefties and liberalism.
So that,
okay,
we can put a hand out for them.
But for the people that are really feeling like they're buying all the nonsense,
right guys,
Hitler and all of this really,
do you have any technique that gives them sure.
I mean I almost never argue about Trump.
I really try not to.
I mean the platonic ideal for me of a show is never mentioning Trump because I
try to take the long view.
I mean look,
other shows had different roles.
You know,
everybody sees like,
you know,
his or her specific task.
But I feel like mine is to try to take the long view,
not easy in the middle of this new cycle.
Of course I get caught up all the time and that,
you know,
the bullshit of the day but,
but mo,
but I really try to think about like,
well how would this look 10 years from now?
Like Trump will be gone.
I'll be gone,
we'll all be gone.
Cause we actually tie at the end.
It turns out so.
But I want the country 10 years.
But I didn't say like,
what kind of country do you want?
That's the question.
Do you want to live in a place where the individual has the right to dissent?
And I think most people would say yes,
I do.
Yeah.
Is that why the free speech stuff has become so important to you?
Cause I think cause you get that more than foundational.
I mean that's just,
if they can tell you what to say,
they can control what you think and if they can control what you think.
You're not fully human.
And so you're really,
you're not fighting for a political party or an ideology or fighting for your
humanity.
I believe that that's what I was taught as a child by liberals and they were
right and I bought it then by the way.
And so the ACL,
you stood up for Clearance Brandenburg who is not only at literally a clansman
from Ohio,
but a moron like literally a moron.
He was the least appealing person ever.
And they stick their entire credibility on defending this guy.
Why'd they do that?
They did it,
of course,
to preserve the absolute right of free speech for the rest of us.
And they made the country better.
When you abandon that dude,
it's over.
And now you see what comes out of the ACO and you're like,
you're not,
you're not defending free speech.
You're clearly a progressive group.
They're opposing frequency.
They issued a statement saying no,
some speeches is too offensive.
Really.
Cause you defended the right of Nazis to march through Skokie,
which everyone forgets had the highest percentage of Holocaust survivors of any
town like outside Israel.
Yeah.
I mean it was the most offensive thing you could do.
And they defended it and they lost a lot of money doing it.
Like they lost a ton of donations doing it,
but they defended the principal.
And I noticed you've gotten 80 instructions book,
should we talk about there?
Here.
So there are people like her are Dershowitz are these former ACL you board
members who were like totally bewildered by this.
Not because we care about the ACU is institution,
who cares?
It's some dumb nonprofit.
But because the principles are literally foundational.
Yeah.
All right.
So let's,
let's jump back for just a second here.
So I want to talk about Fox generally.
Yeah.
So first off,
you guys are doing something right.
And I don't mean just you hear clearly,
if you look at the ratings,
I just looked at this thing and it's like the last bottom 20 shows are all CNN.
Yeah,
the top 10 are basically all fox.
Maybe there's one MSNBC show in there beyond just you.
What do you,
what do you think that Fox is just doing all right?
You know,
being slightly different.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I would argue that the fee,
I mean I can only speak for my shot,
I'm only in charge of an hour of the,
of 24 but you know that it's actually worth defending the principles as distinct
from the individuals or the political figures in over time.
Like you're not embarrassed to do that.
It's worth doing.
But I think as a business matter and just sort of a matter of life,
if you're the guy who's not entirely with the herd and you're like,
actually no,
I,
it's a little bit different.
You know,
you go to the 19 other stores and you can buy this one product and I've got a
different product.
I mean,
I don't think,
why is that bad?
Yeah,
so that just seems obvious that [inaudible] is how offensive that is.
It's like fog and I've worked,
I've worked at CNN,
I've worked at MSNBC,
I worked at PBS,
I worked at Esquire,
I'm,
and I've worked at like a million different liberal publications and television
channels and they're all selling exactly the same product.
And then there's Fox in the mainstream landscape that's different.
Just one channel is different.
And the,
the feeling overwhelming feeling is that should not be allowed.
Like I can't believe that they're allowed to say what they're saying.
We need to shut them down.
Well that's the irony.
It's like you guys are the only ones that will put me on.
I will gladly go on CNN or MSN.
You get on those channels.
I've never been asked.
I can't just show up there and bang on the door.
But you guys call me and nobody,
every time I've done your show,
it's alive.
I never know what you're going to ask.
Worse.
And,
and same thing with some of the other shows and it's like,
I will go where I can talk to people.
Exactly.
I don't,
I don't want to be edited and misrepresented,
which,
so I don't know that I would trust a lot of these other,
you know,
um,
okay.
So that's sort of,
but it's just so uninteresting.
I mean,
if everybody's saying repeating the exact same pieties diversity is our
strength,
our children,
our future or whatever this sort of banality is that you think is profound.
If everybody is saying the exact same thing,
like that's just boring.
I like to have,
I like to have people on who surprise me like what you do.
You know what I mean?
Like that.
Just because again,
I'm more curious.
I mean,
I'm a human being.
I want to think about it.
Does it ever drive you crazy to just be in the,
in the constraints of what television is?
Yeah.
You know,
like,
cause we've done segments where it's like,
you know,
we've got maybe six minutes and I feel like I just,
and then you're like,
Reuben,
I'll see you next time.
You know?
Yeah.
I mean,
I was a writer before I went into TV and one of the reasons that I failed a
couple of times pretty spectacularly in TV is because I didn't understand the
medium and I didn't respect it.
I was like,
I'm a writer,
I'm a deep person.
Here I am in the shallow medium.
And what I didn't understand is it TV is,
it's complete,
it's a completely different thing and it's got its own requirements and its own
rules and you need to understand what it's capable of and is capable of great
things.
It's just not capable of everything.
You know what I mean?
It's not capable of explaining concepts,
complex concepts,
just that's not what TV is about.
Someone was for is said odd to you that the interview,
the real long form this like just sit down with another human being that you
know,
CNN booted Larry King,
which I think was the beginning of the end for them.
So smart.
I think that I really believe it.
I mean I've never heard anybody else say that,
but I argued that when I worked there.
Yeah.
So you,
so you were,
because they were getting rid of him.
I think he told me he was here a couple of weeks ago.
He said,
I thought it was the number one rated show is still on the network.
It was number two at the time.
And they said no,
no,
we're done 30 years audios.
Right.
And they also ended crossfire,
which had become a kind of perversion of its former self but I was in both
versions of it and at one point cross fire was like a public service,
you know,
to sort of equally matched something shift with crossfire.
Cause I do remember watching you on crossfire watching those guys and it was so
it became partisan,
which is uninteresting.
Yeah.
Nobody wants to hear what your team thinks.
We already know.
What's interesting is when we throw up an idea or a policy and we deconstructed
and we have two fairly evenly matched people,
you know,
kind of competing for you,
like w.
So anyway it became something much more.
But the idea was always a good idea.
And especially the idea of Larry King,
I pitched that show too many different channels,
black curtain to people,
hour long conversation.
And my argument was this will rate,
people want this,
there's none of it.
And everyone's like good things.
So we need to interstitials and graphics and it's like they love interstitials.
It's unbelievable.
And now of course with youtube it's like you look at the numbers that you're
getting and others are getting with that exact format and they're huge.
So it turns out,
yeah,
of course there's a market for that.
Why wouldn't there be,
how much of all of this,
everything we're discussing here and so much of what you're doing on your show
is just that people are just tired of having their intellect insulted.
Totally,
completely.
We'll look at television versus movies.
If you had told me 30 years ago that the most interesting,
you know,
visual art being created would be in television,
scripted television.
Like what?
I don't think so.
That's the province of morons.
It's like,
you know what I mean?
Right.
Full House.
But,
um,
but it turned out to be true because to stand up for Bob Saget,
right.
I actually know Bob Saget,
Bob Saget and he's actually very smart.
But the point is that there is,
especially when we're all narrow casting,
when you don't need to reach,
you know,
80 million people when you can 3 million and that is a more than viable
commercial proposition.
You can aim at an audience that wants that and there is a substantial audience
that does.
Yeah.
Okay.
So Fox News,
we get it.
Some things are clearly going right and by ratings and everything else.
Is there anything that Fox is doing that you think is wrong?
Is he too close to the president or,
or anything?
You know,
I,
I mean,
I mean I'm,
obviously I'm dodging the question.
Even if I had a real answer,
I would run from that question because I worked there.
I have to ask him.
But if I'm being completely honest,
no,
I'm not a huge,
I'm so caught up in our hour and I'm so,
it's such a hive in my show and we have like,
you know,
I intentionally hired really smart,
smarter than I am people.
Um,
that I don't have a sense sometimes of the larger programming.
I would say as a general matter,
I've always tried not to be aligned with any politician because in the end,
no matter how sympathetic it might be to the message,
it's a politician and I'm not,
if I want it to be a policy maker,
I would be one.
Cause it's pretty low bar for that.
It turns,
it turns out,
I mean [inaudible] right,
exactly.
So do you ever think about it?
Not for two seconds.
I would never want,
I mean I live in that world so I know what it is.
I don't want that.
I have a journalist temperament.
I like to watch.
I like the freedom to say what I really think is true.
I don't want,
one thing I will say about Fox,
which I'm grateful for every single day and this is Rupert Murdoch.
They don't,
they do not control what you say.
I've had this show for two years,
almost exactly two years now.
A single time as someone called it.
Well no one calls me at all,
but like no one calls.
It is like,
I can't believe you said there's nothing like that.
Pure editorial freedom.
So like why is that not a great job?
Yeah,
no,
I mean,
and I know it again,
I just want to illustrate because people don't understand that every time I have
gone on your show that we,
you know,
they give you some sense of what we're going to talk about and that's it.
We go live it's life.
And if you want to say something insane,
like we can't stop you.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and I would say another thing is the way TV works,
at least at our network.
But I think this is true.
When I worked at the others,
it was also true.
The shows have enormous autonomy.
They really do.
I mean,
there's not a morning call where it's like,
here's our line on this or that or the other.
It's like I never talked to any,
I talked to my executive producer,
Justin Wells,
who I love and a lot of my other producers all morning and she's in the car
parked outside.
It was just doing a show like,
here's where I think we should do.
There's,
I mean,
we can do whatever we want.
Yeah.
What's,
what's your day to day like?
Go over there.
So I know what it's like to do.
I do a couple shows a week and I'm doing long form and this way,
but we're not doing a zillion segments and all and all the interstitials and all
that stuff.
What's your sort of day to day?
Tucker wakes up.
He's got a show that night.
Yeah.
I mean,
I try and I'm married.
I've been married for 27 years.
I really like my wife.
My kids are all gone,
so I really try and stay home.
I mean,
the key in daily TV is not to go insane.
That actually is like the whole deal right there.
If you can keep from becoming an insecure sort of bag of,
um,
do you mean that just because of the media criticism and just constantly
worrying about ratings and like the whole,
the whole trick of bays that,
but just the medium itself leaves most anchors at some point feeling totally
exposed and alone it's like I'm out here,
you know,
I've got a staff of 80 people or whatever,
but in the end I'm out here live.
It's just me.
I'm taking all the crap and no one's backing me up.
I mean every person in the business feels that way at a certain point and then
you start to feel like,
you know,
no one understands it,
you know what I mean?
And you actually become so self pitying and self involved that no matter how
much they pay you,
your deeply unhappy and then you started acting erratic ways and like look at TV
and you know exactly who's going through this.
Right?
Everybody except me because I keep,
my world's so small,
we're not,
I'm married,
my high school girlfriend,
I live walking distance from my dad and my brother and my college roommate.
And best friend and that's who I talk to every day,
every day.
And uh,
and the reason I do that is because I love them,
but also because I don't want to feel the way that most people on TV do.
I want,
I want to talk to people I love and trust and,
and I want my security and happiness to come from those relationships and not
from the affirmation I get on television because you will become a crazy person.
Someone once said to me ahead of a TV network,
one said,
what do you think my job is?
I said,
I don't know,
running a TV network.
And he goes,
no,
it's keeping millionaires from killing themselves.
My job.
Yet,
how dark is that?
That's also true.
It's like his job was to keep the people from going totally bananas because the
medium itself drives you crazy and you're doing this.
No booze,
no cigarettes anymore.
Right?
You got any vice,
the booze is easy.
Drinking coffee.
I drink a lot.
Voltaire levels of coffee.
Not quite as impressive effects,
but yeah,
I like quit smoking four or five years ago and,
but I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I wouldn't call it advice,
but I'm,
uh,
I'm,
enthusiastic user of nicotine gum and laws and Joe's because I think they really
have improved my life like a lot,
I think,
I mean,
I don't want to,
you know,
endorse the products,
but I'm not sure what the downside is of using nicotine.
There's a huge downside from smoking.
Of course,
the target gives you cancer and emphysema,
but,
uh,
I don't think that we've shown that nicotine for people who don't have blood
pressure problems and I don't,
um,
hurts you.
And I think there's a lot of evidence that that's great.
Yeah.
All right.
So I want to spend the remaining time really focusing on the book.
We,
we sorta did.
Yeah.
I think we did everything.
We did everything else,
but let's really focus in on the book.
Okay.
If,
if we're on the brink of a revolution,
what are your prescriptions to say?
But I mean,
I think the first thing you need to do is cool the temperature a little bit.
President's not good at that.
That's not his by temperamentally.
He's incapable
of doing that.
I don't think he sees it as an important thing to do.
So is that,
do you think the fundamental,
like sort of if we're looking at this just at a,
at a base level,
that,
that Trump's temperament and the way the media is with him,
is that sort of the root of everything else,
the volatilities,
the problem?
I mean,
I,
I think that we needed to awaken the people in charge,
not simply of our political system but also of our economy and our culture from
their stupor.
You know,
hey,
you're not listening.
We're going to let this orange guy to wake you up.
I actually think that was a useful thing and necessary thing.
But repeated cycles of political volatility,
like break your country.
Obviously there are a million examples of this and it's obvious.
So,
um,
you need to calm people down in the main way.
You calm people down as the way you come children down,
which is you explained to them as simply and clearly as you can.
Why?
What's happening is happening while you're making these decisions and you give
them some sense that they have some controller,
total control,
but some control over the decisions that you're making.
You know,
you and franchise.
Then we bring them in.
In a democracy,
you need to,
I mean the system is predicated on the idea.
So you need to say to people,
look,
you know you want x,
Y,
and z.
You elected this guy to build a wall.
We think of Wallace stupid.
We don't think it's going to work.
We think it's kind of embarrassing actually.
It doesn't matter.
We're going to do it because you have demanded it.
You have to kind of give people a sense that the democracy,
Israel,
if they think it's fake,
they think it's really an oligarchy posing as a democracy,
what are they going to do?
You didn't want to think about that.
So just practice democracy a little bit would calm things down a lot.
Is anyone doing it better than us,
like for all the sort of anger at each other right now.
And it's funny cause you know,
I spend time on Twitter where it seems like the civil war has begun already.
And then I get out there in real life and I'm on this tour and it's like I need
thousands of peoples all across the middle of the country who are wonderful and
open and decent and all those things.
Um,
but I lost my question in that.
What was the point of that?
I mean,
is it actually as bad as it seems in,
has anyone,
any other country more stable and happy
pure than ours?
Oh,
that was it.
Yes.
It's somewhat here.
Is there an example to look at?
Because I see all these people always complaining and as you said,
it's easier to break things and burn them down than it is to build.
So all these people are always,
oh,
look at these countries,
look at the know,
always said,
look at the Nordic countries.
That seems to be the big one.
Look at that.
Sweden and you know,
even though Sweden's got all sorts of problems right now,
you're one of the only people covering it.
Actually.
Um,
I'm one of the only sweets on television.
Maybe that's why you Swedish.
My name was Carlson.
Oh,
all right.
There you go.
I've got a lot of Ikea and [inaudible].
Not In any meaningful sense.
Swedish.
I mean,
I guess I am genetically Swedish stuff that I even care about that stuff.
One,
1000,
check.
Um,
but I mean that those are not models we can replicate for obvious reasons.
Is the country of what Sweden's got 8 million people go.
I'm telling something like that anyway.
Uh,
no.
Who Does it look?
Nobody does it better.
There's no greater country.
I don't a foreign passport.
I'm stuck here.
I plan to do everything I can for the country because I have a longterm interest
in it and I don't want to move anywhere else.
I can't think of anywhere better.
How Pine Switzerland's pretty nice,
but there's no humor allows.
They're probably the,
anyway,
the point is,
um,
no,
I,
you could look at countries and see their ruling classes doing things you wish
ours did.
There's no country I kind of despise more than China.
But one thing I do admire about China is that its ruling clique,
uh,
thinks long term about stability.
That's their overriding concern.
Now of course that's rooted in their desire to hold onto power,
which is ignorable I get it.
But they understand how important continuity and stability are to the site.
So they think deeply and they don't make the right decisions all the time.
Obviously the one child policy is a disaster,
but they,
that's how they think.
And I wish we thought that way.
I think we've to internalized libertarian economics as a model for everything
that like it's always virtuous to destroy this thing and build something new.
And what we don't understand is like that's not,
people are not capable of that on,
on at scale,
like 325 million people can't deal with tearing down in remaking the society.
Every generation.
They just can't,
they'll go crazy.
And so we need to identify the things that we want to preserve and actively work
to preserve them.
And,
and I would start with the bill of rights.
So do you think any of the people right here,
these beautiful characters,
your character's Maxine waters and Mitch Mcconnell and Nancy Pelosi,
who else do we have on there?
I'm upside down.
Hillary Clinton.
Bill Kristol.
Bill Chris Stover.
Yeah.
Bayzos is this,
I'm upside down here.
That's Lindsey.
Lindsey Graham.
Oh,
well,
okay.
So I actually wanted to sort of get Lindsey into this somehow.
He's a little Pudgy,
are there than in real life.
Um,
he's become sort of like a,
like a star said elite.
Like what do you make of sort of these republicans that like even Mitch
Mcconnell,
like they seem like they've got a little juice at the moment.
Kevin,
our thing did something,
well,
they did the right thing and they are on the cover of my book,
not because of that or any real political reason.
Um,
particularly Lindsey Graham is there and it's described inside the,
he's the embodiment.
And I like Lindsey Graham and I think he's smart,
but he's the embodiment of a phenomenon that I think is really destructive,
which is the refusal of people to learn from the failures that they created.
And so like,
it's okay to have supported the invasion of Iraq.
I did.
What's not okay is to 17,
you know,
15 years later look at it and be like,
no,
that wasn't a mistake.
And No,
I refuse to learn from what happened.
And yes,
I think we should do it again like that.
That's something for which you should be held responsible.
That's my only point.
It's like I catch my kid's doing something wrong.
I'm not surprised that they did something wrong,
but I demand that they can see they did something wrong and I make them try and
learn from it.
That's just basic.
Yeah.
All right,
so let's do a,
I know there's nothing that people in television doing more than predictions.
We got intellectual
because I don't like accountability is the problem.
All right,
so you seem pretty open to this.
So,
uh,
look,
I had Glen back on last week.
He was great.
He was,
look,
this is a guy who if you haven't sat down with them and allow you,
okay,
good.
Like this is a guy who admits freely admits now that he was part of the problem,
that he was one of the people that led to the polarization and he's trying to
fix it.
Yes.
I can't,
you know,
people will say,
well his motives,
he just wants whatever money it,
it's like people's made.
Oh yeah.
And I don't want to attack people.
Yes.
If you repeatedly show me that your motives are bad side,
but I see a guy who genuinely trying to fix some things.
Um,
so when I discussed this with him about the midterms,
we sort of agreed basically that the only option that I see that is remotely
possible here for the betterment of the country going forward,
the Democrats kind of have to be destroyed so that they can rebuild.
I don't otherwise,
if they do well in these midterms,
we ended up in two years of impeachment and then it's like that,
that revolution thing that you think we're on the brink of.
I agree with that.
And the reason is not because Trump is inconvenienced or impeached or whatever
the reason is that the problems that led to Trump's ascent are unaddressed.
I mean that's,
that's you know,
the,
the dying of the middle classes is the core problem and no one is talking about
it.
And Trump,
I have to say sometimes makes it easier not to talk about it because he seeks to
be the person people talk about anyway.
You know,
the problem.
Um,
yeah,
I mean I think the ideas need to be repudiated really clearly.
Like you don't win when you say that the guilty have an obligation to prove
their innocence.
I'm sorry.
We're not rewarding that.
Yeah.
W was that the ultimate like sort of just obvious way this all was going to go
like everything with identity,
politics and everything else and believe all women or because when you grew up
everybody,
you can't have anybody that wanders.
Like,
so the cabinet thing really was kind of the like did it seem obvious to you?
It seemed obvious to me.
That's what it felt like.
The way the reaction
bully obvious.
And I mean,
I got caught up.
I mean,
I say it's obvious,
but I also got caught up as I always do in my sort of literal like,
but wait a second,
what about Ted Kennedy or whatever when I should've been far more sophisticated
in just said,
yeah,
what you just said,
which is of course they're doing this because they have to do it.
And this is kind of the logical apogee of identity politics anyway,
that no one is really human.
We're all just sort of component parts of a larger whole of a group.
And we have to act as a member of a group.
We can never act alone.
Um,
you know,
our,
our unique humanity cannot be acknowledged.
I mean,
you must,
you,
yeah,
you must deal with this all the time.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm like a straight white man,
so like,
you know,
whatever,
I guess I'm acting according to type,
but if you're not,
you know,
so anyway,
you know exactly I'm talking about it's,
yes.
And I should have known that of course.
But the point is,
I don't think that most people buy that or want to buy.
They don't want to live in that country where you're required by your DNA to act
a certain way.
Like what?
So what makes you different from a robot at that point?
And these are them,
the exact same people who are now defending Elizabeth Warren,
of course,
could not be more fraudulent in which is,
have you had any,
have you had a native American tribes?
Men or a Gore?
Yeah.
Gorgeous.
I mean,
I have to say,
I think that story for me has been a happy respite from all this heavy stuff
cause it's just so hilarious.
Oh yeah.
How loud is it for Joe Smith and Warren is,
but I do think there's a deep question at the bottom of it.
Not even at the bottom,
at the very top of it,
which is like,
should your DNA determine your life?
And maybe I'm just too American or too California or something.
But no,
I don't think it should.
I don't think you're responsible for what people,
you never met you.
I think you're responsible for the decisions that you make.
I don't think we should hurt you because of your eye color or your height or
your race.
I mean like if,
if you start to accept that it's okay to inflict group punishment on groups,
then like,
I mean isn't that the whole lesson of the 20th century that that's wrong and
that's a culdesac that ends in bloodshed.
Yes.
So why are we accepting this and everyday on TV,
one of the main pros,
last thing I'll say,
but one of the main problems with our coverage is that it's brought to us by
dumb people and I really think finance,
the whole finance world is partly to blame 40 years ago,
like Smart Evan Thomas from Newsweek lives used to live on my street.
I haven't.
Thomas a very smart guy went to Harvard,
you know,
he's kind of liberal,
whatever,
but he's legitimately smart,
smarter than I am.
He left Harvard and went to work at Newsweek because that was kind of an
acceptable path.
Now what percentage of Harvard seniors are going to Newsweek?
Another.
They're going into private equity.
So what's you're left with this,
it's almost,
it's almost like medieval England where the,
you know,
under private sure that the first son gets the estate and the second son has to
like figure it out or becoming a army officer,
a vicar or something.
It's like we're getting the dumb people were getting the,
you know,
people who can't think for themselves or all of a sudden winding up his cable
news anchors.
It's like,
what?
Do you know what I mean?
I do know what you mean.
That's why I,
that's why I'm on youtube with all the,
were going smart of you to,
if you know what I mean.
Listen man,
you know the first video that I did in a in 2018 was a that I thought this was
going to be the year of unusual alliances and I would say,
I would say this is right up there because I consider this a a great alliance
and I think you're doing great work and all that stuff.
Not that you need.
Yeah.
Look anybody that,
it's really simple.
If you it,
if you feel a moral obligation to scream at people in restaurants,
if you disagree with their political views,
you're not on my side.
And if you don't,
you are.
So it's like I don't,
you know what I mean?
This is such an intense moment.
It's thrown everything into stark relief.
I just care about aligning myself with people who believe in the individual and
freedom of expression,
period.
I hear you brother.
And for more on Tucker,
watch your mind,
Tucker Carlson Tonight at 8:00 PM eastern on Fox News.